[Musik]
in dieser geschichte geht es um die
frage wieso tatiana kalorien us tochter
marina in der schweiz glück suchte und
nahe basel den tod fand
[Musik]
ich kann immer noch nicht glauben dass
marina wirklich weg ist sie ist immer in
meinem herzen
ich rede täglich mit meiner tochter ich
frage sie dinge und erzählte ihr von
meinen tag und ich bitte gott dass er zu
meiner marine schaut
[Musik]
die agglomeration der ukrainischen
hauptstadt kiew konnte es noch nicht
gewesen sein
marina kalorien er wollte mehr die
besten noten und die schönsten kleider
haben das wollte sie als kind mehr als
eine vertreterin für nahrungszusätze
sein und mehr als hundert franken im
monat verdienen das wollte sie als
erwachsene kurzum sie wollte weg von mir
marina kalorien hatte träume und während
sie darauf wartete dass diese in
erfüllung gingen passierte ihr das leben
[Musik]
ein leben das immer weniger das war was
sie lebte sondern das was ihre mutter
und sie sich vorstellten
marina schuster hier nur alles andere
machte sie im wohnzimmer vor dem großen
spiegel ihr aussehen war ihr sehr
wichtig sie hatte zum beispiel
wunderschöne haare
es gefiel mir dabei zuzuschauen wie sie
sich zurecht macht wie sie sich
frisierte wie sie sich schminkt und wie
sie verschiedene kleider anprobiert das
war wie ein fest für mich ich liebte
diese momente mit einem solchen papier
kam marina kaluga 2005 nach hause
das sei ein vertrag sagte sie ihre
mutter sie gehe in die schweiz als
artistin 2303 franken im monat in der
ukraine ein jahreslohn was erzählt
marina nach ihrer rückkehr über ihre
zeit in der schweiz
sie sagte sie liebe die schweiz sehr ich
zeige ihnen dieses bild hat sie mir aus
der schweiz mitgebracht
das ist meine machen so viel schönheit
wie in der schweiz wäre sie noch
nirgendwo gesehen sagte sie
immer wenn die mutter wissen wollte war
seine art ist in eigentlich genau macht
wurde die tochter wütend und es gab
streit ist die mutter irgendwann nicht
mehr fragte
[Musik]
tatiana kalou inne hatte ein schweres
leben
der mann lief er davon dass marina 14
war unterhalt er hielt sie nie erst als
ihre tochter begann in die schweiz zu
reisen konnte die familie anfangen sich
mehr als das nötigste zu leisten
plötzlich war sogar geld da um eine
kleine eigentumswohnung an zu zahlen
[Musik]
endlich ein silberstreif am horizont vis
eines morgens ein polizist vor der tür
stand und sagte ihre tochter sei tot
mehr wisse er auch nicht auf wiedersehen
was meine tochter passiert ist war weder
zufall noch schicksal und auch nicht
gutes will gott wollte sicher nicht dass
meine marina stirbt ein mensch wollte
ihren tod
ein mensch der nicht viel überlegt
obwohl er selber vier kinder hat dachte
er keinen moment daran dass meine
tochter auch eine familie dass sie eine
mutter hat jung sie weinen wird sie
fragen was das in meinen augen war das
war mord
nicht mehr und nicht weniger einfach
mord fünf autostunden östlich von kiew
liegt sumi eine ärmliche stadt nahe der
grenze zu russland
[Musik]
von hier kommen viele ukrainische
kabarett tänzerinnen so auch elena coach
caro war marina kalorien us beste
freundin
die beiden waren wie jährlich 2000
andere frauen aus nicht eu ländern mit
einer sogenannten l bewilligung in die
schweiz eingereist
dort teilten elena und marina sich eine
wohnung und sie fanden schnell heraus
dass sie viel gemeinsam hatten zb ihr
unbeirrtes streben nach glück
[Musik]
ich sehe mich nicht in dieser stadt
ich habe englisch studiert aber ich kann
hier keine arbeit finden die meine
ausbildung entspricht und will nicht
doch eine stelle finden würde ich sehr
wenig verdienen
damit könnte ich meinem kind keine
perspektive bieten im leben in dieser
stadt gibt es keine zukunft für uns das
ist sicher
wenn elena kotka rover in der ukraine
ist holt sie ihren sohn nikita von der
schule an nikita ist acht jahre alt
seinen vater hat er das letzte mal
gesehen als er noch ein kleinkind war
seither fehlt jede spur von ihm
unterhalt hat er nie gezahlt trotzdem
hat es nikita bisher nie an etwas
gefehlt
elena coach carola ist eine strenge
mutter die kita soll etwas aus den
chancen machen die ihm seine mutter so
hart erarbeitet er soll lernen das nicht
selbstverständlich ist im leben
[Musik]
die kita soll ist zum beispiel schätzen
dass sich die familie im gegensatz zu
vielen anderen jeden tag fleisch leisten
kann
[Musik]
elena kotka rover will weg aus der
ukraine genau wie damals ihre freundin
maria carolina am liebsten in die
schweiz mit einem stipendium an einer
hotelfachschule studieren eine stelle
finden um die kita dann nachholen das
ist caro was großer traum
[Musik]
alles mutter will ich das beste für
meinen sohn er ist das wichtigste für
mich
am liebsten wäre es mir wenn er in einem
anderen land aufwachsen könnte denn er
soll später irgendwo leben wo er die
chance hat das zu werden was er will
ich werde alles tun um das zu
ermöglichen
es sind kurze momente des glücks
denn wenn das geld knapp wird muss elena
kotka rover wieder ein paar monate weg
von zu hause
seine mutter will nur das beste für ihn
das versteht nikita und trotzdem leidet
er wenn sie ins ausland geht der bei
seiner oma ist
ich bin sehr traurig wenn mama weg legt
dann geht es mir schlecht
dann bin ich den ganzen tag traurig ich
will nicht dass sie ohne mich weg geht
[Musik]
im august 2008 war es marina carolina
die weg musste am abend vor dem abflug
in die schweiz sahen sie und elena kotka
rover sich zum letzten mal
[Musik]
marina carolina hatte ihre
eigentumswohnung fast abbezahlt noch
35.000 franken fehlten dann gehört die
immobilie hier
[Musik]
als marina in der schweiz war war sie
unzufrieden
ich erinnere mich an unseren letzten
kontakt kurz bevor das alles passierte
sie schrieb mir sie habe das alles satt
sie wolle ihr leben ändern
sie können nicht so weitermachen das war
eine recht lange sms korrespondenz
normalerweise wechselten wir nur ein
paar worte ohne viele fragen
hallo wie geht's gut und dir fertig aber
an jenem abend fühlte ich dass sie etwas
auf dem herzen hatte sie war sehr
nachdenklich
das war eine woche bevor sich marina
kalorien als mörder nachts um vier auf
den weg macht
[Musik]
murat k kaufte unterwegs einen kanister
und füllte ihn mit zehn litern benzin
damit und mit absicht zu töten fuhr zum
cabaret moulin rouge in augst im kanton
basel-landschaft und legte feuer das er
marina kalorien ein jener nacht
ermordete war zufall
sie kannte murat k nicht und er sie auch
nicht eigentlich hatte es auf jemand
anderes abgesehen
den einkauf im supermarkt kann sich
tatiana kaluga eigentlich nicht leisten
sie arbeitet bei der lokalen verwaltung
und verdient 120 franken im monat
das muss für zwei personen und reichen
für sie und ihren 17 jährigen sohn den
sie in zweiter ehe hatte auch jener mann
ist dir davon gelaufen auch er zahlte
bis heute nie unter hand und trotzdem
muss jeden tag etwas zu essen auf den
tisch
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie es weitergehen soll
ich kaufe sehr sparsam ein immer nur in
kleinen mengen im sommer pflanze ich
gemüse und konserviere es für den winter
aber gewisse dinge muss ich trotzdem mir
einkaufen
ich drehe jede münze zweimal um bevor
ich sie aus gebe aber mein portemonnaie
ist ende monat immer leer
sozialer kalorien er musste nach dem tod
ihrer tochter irgendwie weiter
funktionieren obwohl sie die vergangenen
jahre wie in einem nebel erlebt wie und
warum ihre tochter ums leben kam wusste
sie all die jahre nicht der fall ist
nicht nur eine tragödie sondern auch
eine verkettung von kommunikationspannen
das gipfelte darin dass vom flughafen
eines tages ein anruf kam ist hieß es
sei ein paket für die familie gekommen
mehr wisse man auch nicht es war die
urne
tatiana kalorien das leben gab einzig
der sohn noch sinn und struktur mit
banalen dingen wie dem abendbrot das
jeden tag für ihn zubereitet
[Musik]
alexander war zwölf als seine
halbschwester starb um den verlust zu
verarbeiten hatte angefangen lieder zu
schreiben
[Musik]
in meinen texten geht es darum was ich
jeden tag an den straßen meiner stadt
erlebe was ich für gefühle hatte in den
letzten vier jahren alles was geschehen
ist was ich für sorgen hatte ich
schreibe über alles was mit mir passiert
ich schaue zum beispiel aus dem fenster
und sehe die blätter fallen und erinnere
mich daran wie ich mit meiner schwester
spazierte als kind bekommen mich gefühle
ich setze mich hin und schreibe darüber
[Musik]
alexander macht eine lehre als
automechaniker
obwohl in dieser beruf überhaupt nicht
interessiert in der schule haben sie
herausgefunden dass er hoch begabt sei
aber für ein studium fehlt der mutter
das geld
natürlich hatte ich andere träume für
mein leben als automechaniker zu werden
aber die ukraine ist kein land für
träume
lange wird alexander seine abende nicht
mehr zusammen mit der mutter verbringen
irgendwann wird er ausziehen und seine
mutter wird alleine zurückbleiben
wenn mein sohn beschließt selber eine
familie zu gründen heißt das nicht dass
ich ihm verliere ich habe mich auch
darauf gefreut dass marina eines tages
seine eigene familie haben und weg gehen
würde denn eine mutter kann nur dann
glücklich sein wenn ihre kinder auch
glücklich sind
der in ankara will ihrem sohn nikita
zeigen wo sie aufgewachsen ist
ihre elterliche wohnung wurde inzwischen
zu einer studenten-wg umfunktioniert in
[Musik]
elena kotka rovers einstigem
kinderzimmer machen heute zwei angehende
ökonomen ihre hausaufgaben
natürlich wollte ich wie jedes mädchen
einen prinzen auf einem weißen pferd
treffen und irgendwann in einem schloss
leben und viele kinder haben was man als
mädchen ebenso trend mittlerweile ist
elena kotka rover 30 jahre alt und ihre
träume aus kindertagen sind dir irgendwo
unterwegs abhanden gekommen dass du
irgendwann eine wohnung kaufen kannst
wenn du dein geld auf anständige art und
weise verdienen willst kannst du gleich
vergessen
wir leben in einem land von haien
du bist selber ein hai und frisst
kleinere fische oder du wirst gefressen
du hast nur diese zwei möglichkeiten
rache hass und eifersucht trieben wodka
in jener nacht richtung augst genau drei
monate zuvor war seine beziehung mit der
besitzerin des cabarets mühe ruhe in die
brüche gegangen
nun hat er nur noch einen wunsch sie und
alles was mit dir zu tun hatte zu
zerstören
am tag nach der tat wurde murat kaya
festgenommen und erfuhr dass er drei ihm
völlig unbekannte tänzerinnen auf dem
gewissen hatte eine marokkanerin einer
russin und die ukrainerin maria carolina
seine ex geliebte war den flammen
entkommen
[Musik]
murat k wurde wegen dreifachen mordes zu
einer lebenslänglichen haftstrafe
verurteilt
all das haben marina kalorien us
angehörige erst jetzt vier jahre nach
der tat von uns erfahren auch dass der
tatort kanton der kanton basel
landschaft an bietet ihnen eine
genugtuung zu zahlen erfährt die familie
von uns die ukrainische botschaft in der
schweiz sagt sie habe den entsprechenden
brief weitergeleitet tatiana kaluga und
ihrem sohn ist er allerdings nie
angekommen
was der kanton basel-landschaft anbietet
wäre für die familie ein vermögen
immerhin 35 tausend franken
die familie hofft nun auf die
unterstützung der schweizer vertretung
in kiel
denn das vertrauen in die ukrainischen
behörden haben tatiana carolina und ihr
sohn alexander mittlerweile vollständig
verloren
und weil marina kaluga in der schweiz
starb möchten sie den schweizer
botschafter bieten ihnen dabei zu helfen
zu ihrem recht zu kommen
mit der genugtuung von zufälligerweise
genau 35 tausend franken könnte die
familie ihre hypothek bei der bank
bezahlen und wäre endlich die quälende
angst los dass sie ihre bescheidene
eigentumswohnung bald verlieren könnten
erzählt tatjana kalorien
er sei eigentlich nur für die interessen
von schweizer bürgern in der ukraine
zuständig sagte botschafter darum tue es
ihm leid aber er müsse sie
zurückverweisen an die ukrainischen
behörden ökologie da muss ich aus land
und das haben wir besprochen miteinander
was ich aber ab haben ist das mini vor
der botschaft du musst gebe hört
sensibilisiert für den fall dass ich
jetzt neu den nächsten tagen oder
schieber als ministerium uns imponiere
über den überfall über die kontakte
nicht kann und wo nicht so attraktiv ist
eine begleitmaßnahme briefe
er stehe der familie fortan für alle
fragen zur verfügung versichert und der
botschafter und er werde alles tun damit
dieses formular bis ende 2013 ausgefüllt
und beglaubigt sein andernfalls verfällt
der anspruch auf die genugtuung nämlich
ich danke euch dafür dass ihr dieses
treffen möglich gemacht habt ich danke
dem schweizer botschafter
er war sehr mitfühlend ich glaube ihm
dass er mir wirklich helfen wird obwohl
er eigentlich gar nicht zuständig ist
dafür bin ich ihm und der schweiz sehr
dankbar
die schweiz ist ein gutes land und ich
freue mich dass meine tochter die chance
hatte die schweiz zu sehen und dort zu
leben dass mir dieses land jetzt helfen
will
dafür danke ich allen von herzen
der schweizer botschafter hat sein
versprechen gehalten die abwicklung der
formalitäten ist dank ihm angelaufen die
familie wird ihre genugtuung aller
voraussicht nach schon bald erhalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]